welcome back to trash Tuesday
today in studio as our current kalila
replacement we have someone very similar
I've also Bobby Lee
welcome back Mark Normand good to be
back well this is the first time I'm in
the in the studio yes I was in your
weird little therapy in New York I have
no I was like I had so much fun over
that one I was so for the therapist it
was I was like what is going on here we
bought this we got close that was proper
bonded yeah and congrats on the new
special I started it last night it's so
funny oh geez thanks and it's called
Soup To Nuts you got it sister and it's
all over my Netflix
it's crazy on Netflix it's all over my
nose I'm nutting all over it that'd be a
great porn site Netflix not flicks I
gotta get that domain or it's like a
game you guys play when you're teens
yeah yeah Bangkok remember that how does
it feel like how does it feel to have it
out it's been out for a couple weeks now
it's bittersweet because uh it's doing
well people seem to like it but then
they come out and see you and I got no
new stuff I know so you're like now I
gotta pump that [__] out any ideas
audience right right I've got the paper
out there there it just has swastikas on
it but uh yeah it's just I've got to
pump it out because they're like coming
to see you and the agents are like go
make more money yeah like I need a
minute to build material yeah and the
Agents won't let it happen no no they
won't all their other clients are on
strike so they're like we need to do it
I loved how in the opening you started
with like having audience like the
audience shout stuff out and you
reacting to it because I do feel like
that's become a very big part of stand
up especially like
developing new stuff or just like if I'm
trying to get like a crowd work clip or
something right so I was really excited
to see that incorporated in a special
but how often are you not pulling that
off like how often are they throwing
something off and you're like good next
yeah a lot of editing in there a lot of
guys like I'm uh Pakistani and you're
like good job I love your people you
know I know how to pack a fanny
um
foreign
[Music]
let therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today
to get 10 off your first month that's
better help hllp.com Tuesday head to
factormules.com trash50 and use code
trash50 to get 50 off that's code
trash50 at factormeals.com trash 50 to
get 50 off hello sluggies
um what a fun episode thank you for
joining us
um I am on the road on the welcome to
anniewood tour you can see me in San
Francisco at Cobbs that was so fun it
sold out last time I can't wait to see
you guys September 15th and 16th I'll be
in Austin Texas in October La Jolla in
October at The Comedy Store I think I'll
be filming my special there
so that will be extra special and I'll
be in San Jose and Houston and a lot
more dates are getting added so go to
annieleterman.com shows and you can see
me every Thursday on anyone and uh Annie
wood and friends at The Comedy Store the
date will be posted so check my
Instagram
um I don't know the exact date yet but
you will see it September something
hi you guys I am so psyched that for the
first time ever I'm coming to Madison
Wisconsin in two weeks September 14th
through 16th I'm really looking forward
to this I'm definitely a cheese Midwest
girl and then I'll be in DC Boston
um San Diego Detroit Chicago San Jose
and more you can get tickets at Esther
onice.com I can't wait to see you guys
[Music]
now I'm gonna shoot a special suit and I
was thinking I like pace so much that
I'm the editing is going to be hard like
all of a sudden I'm going to be like
over in one corner that'll be fine I
mean Chris Rock is like a [__] yeah
but didn't he do his live where you
watch the whole thing well his old ones
are paced yeah you'll be fine but then
he goes to like Africa in one remember
he like oh yeah he like all of a sudden
isn't like another yeah in another
outfit there's black people and then
there's Africans but yeah he pays you'll
be fine pacing is good it keeps people
interested do you do that at all your
live shows where you take like the
audience stuff is that why you
Incorporated it in the special no
because uh hey I hadn't seen anyone do
it and everybody's like you gotta get
them up top they click out after like
two seconds if they're bored so I was
like put that in the front so it's it's
kind of action-packed a little yeah I
love the opening like because I'm from
Chicago oh it's so cool to see the L
represented in TV yeah I'm so excited
um what made you decide to in Chicago
well I kind of blew my load in all these
cities you know we're going to shoot at
this date and I'm like well I've just
been here I've just been here I can't
sell another ticket in Chicago we hadn't
been to in a minute so we did it there
and it's a great comedy town as you know
yeah I was so I was also extra excited
because the Vic where you shot it is
there was once a Dropkick Murphy's
concert there that I didn't even know
what they were about these cool kids
invited me and my parents wouldn't let
me go so like the Vic had like a very
childhood like a headphone yeah yeah wow
you were a drop kick gal no I I not at
all oh I just wanted to see who friends
were going the cool people got it and my
parents were like this is not happening
well that was a good protection though
yeah easily drop kicked no I fully would
have died yeah you would have gotten
killed but I'm the only idiot that
booked the theater I was like the
theaters open book it and it was Saint
Patty's Day oh that is
the worst
hammered one guy like hit his girlfriend
stopped the show it was wild to jerk off
yeah yeah
wait because you know in Chicago St
Patrick's Day is insane oh yeah and at
my college which is the University of
Illinois Champaign Urbana they have
something called unofficial St Patrick's
Day where like all the kids start
drinking the Friday before St Patrick's
Day at like 8 A.M all day so maybe it's
because the school is called champagne
that could be why is it the longest name
of a school what is it called University
of Illinois in Champaign okay there's
two cities which I don't fully
understand either but were people like
so reckless hammered yelling out stuff a
lot of that front part of the special
with the crowd work was them being
shit-faced they started the crowd work
sometimes it happens like I guess we're
going here you gotta go there and it's a
Netflix statement so you're like I want
it to be perfect yeah and then you see
some guy like blow me he's like oh [__]
but uh we we pulled it together and we
we got something out of it were you
nervous terrified I was like this is my
shot wait did you do one show we did
four
just for that reason in how many nights
one two nights two so funny to pack in
four on St Patty's Day like let's see
how many [__] up people we can get in
here a lot of editing I'm always
performing on the worst every I've never
taken like the right weekend off ever
I'm always like oh sure this weekend's
open I'll do it and it's always it's
always a drinking thing yeah you're in
Winnipeg and like February oh yeah no
wonder no one would take this I'll be
like I always go to like Tampa during
their like pirate festival I'm like [__]
everyone's always coming with like peg
legs one time I had a guy who literally
come in with an eye patch wow but it
wasn't it was Tampa but it wasn't until
I was like oh are you doing like the
thing but are you trying to pretend that
you didn't love that I was very excited
about it I asked if I could sign under
the eye but did you do any hard hours
but yeah there's always some hey the uh
Strawberry Fest is in town or whatever
and you're like God and then it is like
their main thing yeah for [__] sake
we're gonna go pick strawberries and
then it's like why can't you pick
strawberries and then come to the show I
know or like I went to St Louis or
somewhere I went uh and they were having
like an old-fashioned car thing I'm like
you can't look at cars and then come to
a show right right yeah and they always
they always say it to help you when you
don't sell tickets they're like well
it's not it's not you it's you know
Comic-Con is here or the the kids what
do you call those uh where they
beauty pageant with the little kid those
are hot you're like yeah that doesn't
can conflict yeah no no counter uh cross
culture here no I wish my agents would
do that that would be awesome to give me
like I just go there and then the owner
will tell me and I'm like okay at least
you're not mad at me right right they're
always nice well it's July everybody's
out of the boat you know there's always
some excuse they're mad I feel like
they're mad they're like so pissed at me
they'll be like well I'm like [__] you
where's your marketing exactly when I
started comedy you would go to a club
it'd be full and then you'd leave they
didn't know who you were and it was fun
and then they take out of here if you
look at the breakdown they take out of
your expenses like 600 for like
promotions yeah where I know and then
what if you're a sellout like what if
you're a draw yeah
give me that I know well here we are
guys if you want to know the insides of
yeah sorry what our contracts are wait
so Mark are you actually like literally
on tour right now as the special just
came out yeah I don't know what that
means when people say are you on
yeah exactly but because that seems so
like you said so difficult you just
burned like your hour oh yeah what are
you doing up there it's about 20 minutes
of stuff I got some stuff that I kind of
had on the back burner and then 30 of
like
so black people are late you know just
like trying to uh and Filipino as a
parent I feel like we should call crowd
work uh back burner back Hannah burner
oh she's taking it over I like it I like
it but I will say
um that is a fear of mine too because
I've like the idea of having to go with
all new stuff but do you like announce
this is new I feel like Taylor Thomason
does that she's like come see me work
stuff out that's like I'm gonna do that
every time guys this is my first time
ever doing these jokes I'm so proud of
you it's a killer hour but you're like
I'm working it out I'm just that good
yeah so you got to say that up top and I
think some people like it they're like
oh he's got the notes up here or
whatever but I think most people are
like you know I paid a little I have a
look at you I have a guy who he comments
on every time I go to Philly he like
he's like she brought notes out it was
like 2014. it was like my first
headlining gig I'd ever done yeah he's
like she brings notes out don't go I'm
like come on man what really I'm like
come on give me a break [__]
give me a break what's up with these
losers these Reddit queefs well you know
when you like know them they're there so
often how do I recognize you and you're
like do you love me or do you hate me I
know why are you still around or like
still like you haven't left me all you
do is criticize me but you know every
single thing about me you know more
about me than my father it is weird but
I know them by their name though there's
one guy that like he kept bothering like
he would give two like detailed he would
say things like um he said like I liked
Andy so much more when she lived in her
car like she was so much before she like
had a boyfriend I was like you want me
to like be like miserable suffering
starving to death exactly and then I
like got mad at him once and then he was
like you shouldn't know my name I was
like Ron he's like how do you know my
name but now he like comes to myself I'm
like runs here
Ron's gonna kill you one day no wrong
turns on me again and I'm like now that
I [__] have acknowledge you can't
turn on me again yes he's like the
Selena fan club guy you know I mean
Esther don't act like if we don't have
some no but that's so funny that your
own fan was like why do you know my name
it was the perfect answer that's the
best comeback ever like I want to say
that to someone one day you shouldn't
know me never been signed too we'll do
live shows for Tuesdays with stories and
we're like oh that guy's here again that
we know our whole audience yeah not good
I mean we're glad you come but uh it's a
little embarrassing well though it's how
do you feel about people that come
multiple times in the weekends that is
the worst well she's like I want to do
new material I'm like I I have like it's
psychotic but I'm like I want everyone
to have like a completely unique
experience of course of course so it's
like when they come you're like [__] I'm
just gonna redo I don't want to put
those things in the same order totally
takes the magic out of it they're like
oh I see behind the curtain now because
a joke has to be a surprise yeah like oh
I know where this is going and they
always say no I get it but they're not
laughing yeah I'm like [__] you yeah we
need you we're feeding off you yeah I
feel like
um I went to she told me that I can't
mention this but I have to mention it
every episode I went to the Nickelback
concert whoa and uh it was Monument so I
can't help it you just saw Taylor Swift
and you're bringing up Nickelback well
because Taylor Swift doesn't have this
problem okay so the issue that
Nickelback has is the opposite of us
where they the fans only want the hits
they don't want any new stuff so they
have to sneak new stuff in and
everyone's like so bored and sitting
down in their seats looking at their
phones and then with us it's like I mean
it would be heaven to be able to do this
it would be Heaven
I don't think you would enjoy it though
but you could pull them out like to be
able to pull out like a bit you know has
been killing for 15 years okay so I have
an alternate point of view on this and I
don't know if this is where I stand I
just want to present it but like all
right Jonah Hill with the therapy truck
I always have an alternate point of view
I was um I recently did a show in I
think it was Raleigh or Atlanta or one
of those places but like afterwards
these girls came up to me and they were
like wait we're so upset you didn't do
the dog fetish bit and it was like what
because I so I started this is exciting
I started posting like some of my
material as clips and I I've been so
insecure about it I'm like I can't do
those bits like people have seen it and
Dave keeps telling me like nobody cares
do it and then for that to happen where
they're like no we want to see what you
posted that's very exciting and you're
doing God's work that means that means
we're changing the what they want and if
that if that is what they want that I
can give that I can deliver I can
deliver already written jokes that I
know work yes it's writing the new
material that's the hard stuff but but
um I feel like it's okay to do that as
long as you don't hesitate beforehand
and deliver it weird because you feel
weird about it because I have I had like
my Kanye Yeezy bit that did really well
online and then I feel guilty doing it
but sometimes it just comes up like
someone's wearing Yeezys and I want to
go into it and if I if I do it where I
feel weird and like guilty or something
it doesn't do as well totally but if I
go like deliver like they've never heard
a noise as well no yeah you have to sell
it like ever like with everything I mean
do you ever do repeats or have people
come up to you and be like why didn't
you do this yeah but I don't trust them
because it's always one guy or two guys
they don't speak for the whole audience
so I think if you just play like all new
they're happy yeah but it was at least
go watch it at least encouraging that
like for me like I can I feel like I can
post clips of some things and still do
them I agree Clips is one thing a
special I think is different but a clip
yeah although like yeah sometimes like a
topic like will come up that's something
I did in my special and I'll just throw
it out yeah if it pops into her head
yeah in the moment or whatever is
anybody getting this I think there's
some guy driving a truck going all right
yeah it's always weird how people get in
a relationship and they look shittier
I'm like so now the person you love has
to deal with your disgusting you are
yeah well I look at Todd and I'm like
now I never I never care about like what
he eats or anything and now that we're
getting I'm like you are not gonna be
like a bald fat guy there you go good
for you I won't allow it and I just
smack the taco out of his hand and get
the [__] out of him yeah you hear that
lizzo that's right lizzo and I make him
eat the banana out of my [__]
I like that scenario to me is like
there's no if there's no way it was bad
no there's no way damn come on and also
we got into rock and roll it's fun you
know what do you go be an accountant if
you don't want to eat a banana out of
someone's snatch
I was talking to faheem last night at
the store and he had a good point he was
like we've all been sitting on these
lizzo fat jokes but we're like I don't
want to be mean but now it's like all
right at least Beast
good stuff somebody had a great line
they said uh I'd stand by lizzo but
there's no room
I got a tweeter on stage that was it
somebody tweeted it's on stage it's not
gonna nah nah it's a written that's a
horrible when you do okay sorry we're
going back into County no it's I could
talk comedy all day it's hard to not
talk comedy what else we're gonna talk
about your wife
when did you get married November 11
2022.
uh no it was in New Orleans it was a
perfect night she killed it she planned
the whole thing it was awesome you just
had to show up I just had to show up I
did shrooms did you yeah I was thinking
how [__] up I want to be on my wedding
it helps because it's comics and family
it's worlds colliding and it's emotions
you know and I'm not good with that so I
took some shrooms which might have been
a mistake because I was at the altar and
she looked like already Lang face was
all warped you were never harder yeah
yeah exactly I'm Marrying the wrong
person
I do love Artie Lange Hardy Lang is a
king do you have any sense of what you
do want to have for your wedding I'm
really like I just want no pressure and
fun family like whatever is that your
drink Rock no monster monster no I do uh
five hour energies oh wow you're an
animal yeah how do you do it you must be
[__] blood
yeah all right so I like to [__] blood
it feels good makes me feel alive
there's no blood on my toilet seat what
am I doing you got a bidet of course I
did my first day a week ago and man it
is life changing it's amazing amazing
and they make them very affordable like
I'm sorry they really do yeah but you
can do a range of them there's one in
here there's like a nice like Japanese
toilet I'll be [__] I like you can
pick what color you want the lights to
be in the water damn yeah my [__] comes
out purple I do it blue so it comes out
purple I was on staying at an Airbnb
that had a toilet that when you walked
up to it it would lift the lid and I was
like I don't know how I'm ever gonna go
back to life without this without the
toilet acknowledging your presence yeah
and then I realized my toilet at home
the lid is always lifted like this isn't
a service I need so stupid but like I
got used to it it feels good seeing it
go up like this yeah if you ever worry
like the wind will blow and you'll fall
into it
I want to remake the um Inner Space with
you what's that remember wouldn't that
be good great idea
uh Martin Short uh Quinn Dennis Dennis
Quaid not Randy Randy my favorite Quaid
but I have partied with Dennis Quaid he
gets yes and it's a great story he's a
hunk so she he gets shrunk down and then
he gets ingested by Martin Short so he's
like in his body but he's like a tiny
wait I want that there it is you could
be either Martin you could play either
character honestly it's like the Magic
School Bus yeah it is remember that it's
a Magic School Bus for adults yeah
fun oh it's like Honey I shrunk my uh
oh yeah my lunch a lot of shrinking in
the 80s it was weird never noticed that
before now all shrinks yeah therapy joke
yeah I like it wait so Mark have you
um seen any Taylor Swift concerts lately
no I can't afford it
uh I don't I don't care for the music
I'm I'm impressed with her I just it
doesn't connect with me I'm a
heterosexual 39 year old I will say
two I went to the concert there were
like boyfriends there I did not see any
true straight men like with their Bros
going to the concert which I was
surprised I thought she transcended
really I feel like Naper gotzi loves
Taylor Swift yeah so yeah they're out
there but he has a daughter and a wife
so it could be the daughter involved
involvement but it I was so impressed by
her I felt like sad I didn't know more
of the lyrics She did 44 songs wow and I
know like two two songs really well that
I really like and I realized I don't
even know the lyrics to that and it was
like oh you feel like such a loser wow
everyone knows I know it's it's Bizarro
land but when you're there you're in her
world and it's like you are the loser
I mean every single or she went with
Nikki Glaser which I can't even imagine
Nikki knew everything it didn't get like
a sign Nikki was trying to be like the
little girl she like gives the hat too
it should have been
um no Nikki just like it was so funny to
watch her just truly know every single
word
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
sometimes we're faced with Crossroads in
life and we don't know which path to
take that happens to me all the time I'm
always in some
what do I do liminal space look we have
annoying friends we have friends we talk
about this on this episode we have
people that that are negative or take a
long time on the phone and therapy has
been an indispensable
um part of my life so if you're thinking
of starting therapy give better help a
try it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge and
also like better health has this really
cool Journal feature which I love where
I'm able to kind of put down my thoughts
in between my appointments and I can
bring them up with my therapist on our
next appointment so I love that feature
also like the best part about it is that
if you don't Vibe with a therapist which
happens a lot by the way and it's no
fault no fault of theirs or yours
sometimes sometimes it's just not a
match it's that easy to switch I know
there's so many times I've just gone
back to people because it's like too
awkward right but better help makes it
very very easy let therapy be your map
with better help visit betterhelp.com
trash Tuesday today to get 10 off your
first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday guys
we're busy not only are we busy but some
of us can't be trusted to cook for
others okay that is fine factor is
America's number one ready to eat meal
kit can help you fuel up fast with Chef
prepared dietitian approved ready to eat
meals delivered straight to your door
honestly cooking portioning I don't I
can't like I'm a busy woman I'm on the
go and Factor meals are so delicious and
they're healthy and they make things so
easy and you can choose from over 34
weekly flavor pack dietitian approved
meals ready to eat in two minutes and
level up with Gourmet plus options
prepared to Perfection by chefs and
ready to eat in record time which is
very important to me treat yourself to
upscale meals with premium ingredients
like broccolini leeks truffle butter and
asparagus varicus and also if you're
looking for like a calorie conscious
option ahead of a busy season try
delicious dietitian approved calorie
smart meals with around or less than 550
calories per second I tried to have the
weight the the the scale to weigh out my
food I'm it's just not for me it's not
going to happen so I can't personally
count my own macros that is something I
will never do in this lifetime not it's
not worth my time it's not worth my life
and so Factor doing it for me is what's
up head to factormeels.com trash50 and
use code trash50 to get 50 off that's
code trash50 at factormeels.com trash50
to get 50 off
play your comments I don't know if
you've read yours you should never read
them why it's wild just oh man she looks
like a kid to take that diaper pull to
the side
they can't be that overt about it but
they really they do think they've
discovered you like in a daycare center
like yeah come on that is not true this
hot toddler she's definitely doesn't
have pubes you know I got a hymen all
kinds of stuff I'm gonna [__] her in her
baby ass yeah that I regret writing
she's a spinner size they can't help
themselves yes oh my God that's not true
you guys
[Laughter]
I don't that's the one thing I don't I
don't have the girl little girl thing a
lot of guys love that like young toddler
girl oh my God they do I'm not a lot but
oh I do follow Esther I've never no you
finally no you I'm telling you like in
the past two years you now look like
you're in your 20s before it was like I
was like they need to be on a [__]
list like it really was like you looked
so young
and it was weird but now I'm like I let
them I'm go you can have at her it's
just so weird because people always
trust that you're not doing anything bad
always say this to me and I've literally
never been with anyone who's like let's
like play that up like no one wants
really yes yeah oh I assume the whole
thing yeah no your dates were at a
playground so you're having a Capri Sun
they Spike her like little like Juice
Box yeah yeah exactly have some
Flintstones like a little juice box a
little juice box the squeezer a little
liquid comes out I identified so I go on
a daily to shake their keys in your face
I mean see the sad thing is I would love
that like a date at a playground sounds
so fun no one wants no you do like to be
baby that is funny I know no guys
because they look like pedophiles yeah
they they want it because you look so
little like if they were to do that like
Dave would probably carry around in a
Baby Bjorn oh that would be fun I would
never do that that's why you're naked
but she's naked yeah and going out
what what do you even mean pacifier the
whole thing cradle stroll you in a
stroller would be fun
this is unfair
um what is it like trying to change the
subject married to a fellow stand-up
comedian it's good and bad it helps
because you can have a dialogue about it
yeah I can feel her jokes it's a good
premise but I kind of am the one with
the I could do them I'm on tour baby
let's go yeah it's good because you can
have a dialogue about comedy like we we
all have talked about comedy you can do
that with her so she gets everything
it's not like who what's a Comedy
Central presents what's a tag you know
she understands everything but then it's
also like to explain what your credits
are
yeah what's a premium blend
uh but yeah then but then it's hard
because she's on the road I'm on the
road and uh we're all trying to we're
sitting at dinner like are you gonna use
that
really yeah wait that's actually so fun
that you're actually sitting at dinner
and like coming up with bits to the
point where you have to like divvy them
up oh yeah no that's so annoying are you
kidding comments it's been the worst or
it's like someone kind of like has the
premise and then the other one does the
punch line and then you're like no no
yeah or then when you see your ex and
they're like still doing your punch
lines and you're going and they're
getting like the best and you're going
oh I want to tell people that was mine
yeah that's true I want to tell people I
did that or you're having sex and
something silly happens and we're both
kind of like
that whole queef chunk
like she queef but I thought about yeah
yeah a little baby arm comes out
the old miscarriage that's what I call
her uh for marriage for miscarriage oh
that's great yeah
we'll be on the race towards it we have
to fight
we have to fight over our premises you
guys want kids is that in the cards
it's in the freezer
I got them nice and Frozen up
boys or quarter Asian boys nice oh is he
Asian yeah I never thought I'd see the
day yeah can you believe it I'm bringing
Asians back wow well done there Shang
Wang
is cute yo funny guy yeah he's a great
comic cool dude he's kind of got a
little swag he does his hers like all
along now I saw him in Montreal and he
was doing jokes about like turnips like
smashing doing these jokes about I'm
like God I wish I could do one of those
yes I just wish I could be one of those
like green onions and he's like just
destroyed that's leveling the place I'm
like [__] like I like yeah he's great
he's got a bit about salmon it's the
only like Salmon's a color like I have a
salmon shirt he's like it's the only
color based on the inside of an animal
and you're like yeah
that is scary and it's like I don't know
if he smokes pot or just gives Vibes a
smoking pot like it's like he took like
high ideas and made them right right
Classics we just had Whitney on the
podcast and she's pregnant right now and
I feel like that all gave us like a
little bit of baby fever does that does
that ever happen for guys
an abortion fever
but it's like serotola mosh Rosebud
Whitney a lot of people are getting
Prego it's it's the season it's really
uh bringing like coveralls back too yeah
yeah to me that looks like the worst
thing you'd want to wear when you have
to peel uh oh good point like a onesie
but I guess I don't know but you all you
got your first three minutes hey I'm
trying to kill it I didn't want to keep
it hey I'm not gonna keep it you know
whatever it is so you got like three
minutes oh I'm crowning let me better
yeah yeah exactly Rosebud we did a fully
loaded and she you know it's 18 000
people and she would just walk out and
be like don't worry I'm not keeping it
yeah oh my God kills she kills the baby
right yeah obviously wait do you feel
like you want kids I I want the 25 year
old at dinner at Thanksgiving and we can
all get along but I don't want the
sleepless nights the [__] the grades
the school projects the all that [__]
the uh period oh isn't that good that
you're the dad yeah I really don't have
to have any of it does not do that
that's true I know I feel like it's
interesting that it's good I feel like
Ali Wong does all service by doing like
her pregnancy specials because before
that I just remember thinking like wow
having like a kid as a female comic
sucks and having a kid as a male comic
is like like career change all this
material you're now relating to the
world and then I and I always felt like
it was like uneven but now I think it's
good point yeah Wong did two pregnant
specials Schumer did one pavitsky did a
pregnant thing what is it sorry a lot of
Pollocks around here I've never known
the difference isn't that funny I know
literally I've been calling you the
wrong you didn't even notice what he
said Christina P yeah she does us the
service and Esther does a little Esther
for us yeah Whitney's gonna do one too
yeah no it's now it truly is a trend I
kind of love it yeah yeah we need a
first man pregnant special it's coming
my fiance doesn't look like the pregnant
man speaking of pregnant men
oh my God Walk of Shame
block of Shame whose Bed were you I'm
gonna have to have whose bed where you
live
you're dressed like you had to throw on
your merch shirt to get here
it's calm
it looks like the Playboy Bunny sticker
that I want for my no I honestly thought
we were starting at one time I should
send an extra reminder I almost did no
it was my fault it's my fault my fault
it's all my fault I'm so happy you got
here before one you're good you're early
I love when other people are late it's
like my favorite thing in the world this
is one and not an intentional late
though this is like I really thoughts
aren't intentional
um
what's what's up guys what are we what
are we talking about
preggo comedians I don't I didn't get
any baby fever from from it was like
baby fever from Whitney but it was like
if this person is having a baby because
she seemed last time I talked to her she
was like it would be archaic for me to
have a baby right so I was like okay
we're not having kids and then she's
like praying I'm like [__] are we having
kids right God damn it Whitney what the
hell and that's gonna be the strongest
baby ever because the Percocets and the
purple ball that that baby's fighting
off in the womb dodging like the Matrix
no that's a silver baby that's a summer
baby no you're right I I think I'm gonna
well I told the girls that I was
probably just gonna settle for like a
truck a guy at a truck stop and just
whatever knock it out yeah whoever will
travel whoever [__] me effectively
first is the baby now I okay so wait I
like that term effective cream pie yeah
effective because all cream pies are
effective there's slow motility some of
the sperms are broken up like you want
it you want it with pulp not without
with pulp oh my God you're right have
you ever checked your sperm no but I've
gotten two girls pregnant in my day [__]
yeah I think I'm okay you're good yeah
that's right we talked about this you
paid for three or two three
in my day and you only and you're the
father of only two yeah
one was like a wayward sister right
right there's just some black guy
outside I was like I got it and do you
offer immediately are you like hey I got
this or is it you offer because you want
to be a gentleman but you're secretly
like I need this to happen right so I'll
pay for it I'll make sure that money's
not like an issue and do you go with
them and you give them like porridge
after like to you know porridge well
that I have my sister makes the best
abortion porridge
abortion porch sounds like like the meat
that comes out it does you add it on top
no but I I she does she makes this like
really it's kind of like roscaldo but
it's really good I know you were kidding
but you know how people eat like the
placenta yeah does anyone eat their
fetus is that what they mean
Annie and I want you guys to go on
Reddit Sam tripley's read it and figure
that out
wait a second but do you are you there
throughout the whole process are you
like following up I'm following up make
sure
yeah but uh two were in New York so you
know it's a walking City
so wait what is the pill the pill just
is supposed to go in and just kill it uh
yeah but you have oh it it was
excruciating for me the worst things
about the abortion pill it really caused
it forces contractions so it's a really
oh you have to deliver the baby that's
so sad basically yeah it basically feels
at least for me I don't know I think
some girls it works you know I don't
usually get period cramps so the feeling
of cramps is not
um it feels like period cramps times ten
yeah and you're just sitting there
waiting for it to pass and you look down
you're like I think that's it but it I
wonder if getting kicked on the balls
and period cramps feel the same yeah I
wish I could just have balls one second
to do what it feels like worst feeling I
got hit in the balls uh I posted on my
Instagram and it was a football right to
the balls I was out for a half hour
really yeah you feel in your stomach
it's it's really you've got like
nauseous kind of get nauseous you get
like waves of pain it's brutal I felt
like a lady I had a heating pack on me
nice Scream Wait where is the train
where does the pain travel to like in
your abdomen yeah it goes up it like
hits the intestines I don't know because
it's all connected like you have to shut
no not really but it won't go away it
lingers at pain I feel so bad I was such
a ball puncher in Middle School oh my
brothers my brother in the ball's so bad
do you think if you have balls you'd be
safe you punched men in the balls that
was not men yeah just not men yeah we're
flirting balls are you serious guys
flick each other in the balls balls are
always getting it's so sensitive it's a
perfect Target also yeah it's a [__]
it looks exactly like the speed bag but
wouldn't you be kind of afraid that
there's like something sexual about that
well there were all guys that had
crushes on oh really yeah some dick in
there I didn't know what's in front of
the ball it was my first hand job
technically
my first true hand job was much more
brutal than that oh those are the worst
they probably would have been like the
teenage just like but if you're happy
someone's touching your people that's
true my handjobs are still brutal I'm
terrible at hand jobs it's just getting
going forward
okay just go to the mouth we're at that
age we're still doing dance clubs what
are we doing here
yeah because I have TMJ and I have nasal
valve collapse
I could die giving a [__] so I have
to what a way to go we use the hands and
then she'd be all rigor mortis like
did you see Beau is afraid when um I
haven't seen the air uh yeah there's
like a scene where someone gets like
they die like [__] and they're in
rigor mortis in like a banging position
and it's someone that's you've always
wanted to see topless oh no it's a
female you've always wanted to see
topless I'm not going to give it away
but
um
so what do you get to breathe right that
might that's why I use those but then I
had to stop using them because they
bruised my nose so I have this like is
there a nasal CPAP you could do no I'm
supposed to get it fixed apparently it's
like the hottest [__] ever there's a
nurse ready to just give you like press
compressions if you die you get a piece
of my ear and they use it to like open
up my valves they have done that no they
haven't done it yet I keep waiting
because I don't want to be out for six
weeks you'd look cute though with like a
little bruised up nose yeah but then
it's just gonna look like I got a nose
job but if you but you would if you were
doing that you wouldn't just trim it up
a little too no they don't do that I
would if something is perfect my
insurance you wouldn't notice okay good
nose jobs you don't notice she does not
need a nose job that would be a
nightmare she's a perfect nose that's a
shame because you got some dsls I mean
those lips are made for something and
the teeth are very like they seem like
perfect like lightest scrape just the
lightest yeah like a nibble on the head
but they're nurse shark teeth they have
no um my dentist shaved down my incisors
when I was 15 without my permission so I
have no shark teeth they cause no injury
to penis so you're built for Beach thank
you but apparently the beach babe yeah
and the TMJ doesn't help so that's where
that really horrible hand and then the
only way to help the TMJ is to get BOTOX
and then your muscles aren't strong
enough right
yeah I'm a waste I'm a lost I'm a lost
lover yeah I don't know what I'm doing
damn it's like a really hot gay guy like
all these girls like him but he just
hates clam
because lesbian lesbians I find this is
gonna get ugly
I find lesbian guys aren't really you
know they're short-haired flannel boots
you know and but gay guys or smoke shows
they're all ripped and they're all like
short hair boots
yeah so that sucks for the ladies that
you're like these gorgeous men are all
well also you're talking about a type of
like you're talking about like Butch
lesbians and then so like the gay guy
you're talking about is like a butcher
gay guy too it's like they're like the
equivalent of that type of lesbian is
like a guy in like tights we can sequent
like right right that's what we wouldn't
be like yeah because I I love half gay
boys I love boys that have been with
other boys at some point but I'm not
attracted to the super like quaffed hair
oh okay gay man I need him to be a
little bit more disheveled and dirty
like all right you know that type even
more I think they're called otters yes
[Music]
you know you're like a little hairy thin
not too big like there's bears and
there's otters
yeah you're definitely an otter wait am
I an otter circus seal you're more of
like a muskrat like little we could use
do experiments on you you crawl in yeah
these are otters wait Mark have you done
that I've done the two guy girls shut up
what college come on yeah and I've done
the two girl guy
those guys have done the two guy girl
for sure that's bro we're friends what
yeah side by side worldwide I remember
like I think it's more of like the
Community College hang when it's like
you bang like in the hotel room together
yeah they're not like you're just
banging next year you don't really have
a choice because your friends are there
you don't have money for another room
and then you're like all right one
person starts buying like what are we
gonna just sit here yeah then she starts
blowing the other guy and now it's on
I don't understand like where was I
during the where were you you were
outside the Dropkick Murphy concert
Ryan you're on the phone with your
parents why you're not in the threesome
you made the threesome
oh my God that's crazy like and is that
like a fun memory
it probably get threesome because every
guy's like so much bigger than you Annie
two people against one do you feel like
you can't believe you did that like was
it do you want to do it again no I got
it out of the system but you know it's
College everybody was wild if your wife
was like it's our 10th anniversary it's
time no I wouldn't want to do another
guy with the wife
oh another girl no another guy would be
like crazy that'd be weird I mean item
22 is is eating his words oh he's so sad
now he's so salty about it I don't blame
him hey what's going on with that he had
like a black guy for his wife's birthday
or for their anniversary he had a black
guy is there no jumper thing yeah and
now he's like he's pissed about because
the guy like wasn't respectful it's like
they were disrespectful in what way
though was he just like I think he just
banged her out too hard and then he was
maybe talking [__] a little bit he's a
huge guy yeah he's huge big giant boy I
thought with gold chain imagine she
brought just like an emo like a black
guy that would be great regular penis
wait did she choose the guy or did he
choose him for her hold on I thought
this story was that the this couple does
porn together and then they decided that
she was gonna do a porn with a different
man and the husband was like thought it
was great and cool it was his present to
her okay and then all of his friends and
all these people on podcasts are like
why did you do that and he he like kind
of got embarrassed that he let that
happen well he the guy wasn't like nice
and respectful about it is that true I
mean I guess I'm respectful to her not
to know about him no no no he was like
talking [__]
about the husband yeah I didn't know
that which is hilarious that's how you
want it to end do you want the guy you
let me [__] your wife [__] haha right
what am I gonna be nice yeah I'm gonna
be like oh thank you sorry [__]
everyone I would hire Brad Williams
that's my go-to see we recently got um a
question from a fan or someone was
approached by a couple they approached a
man asking if he would [__] the wife and
let the husband watch okay and he was
like he didn't want to do it if you were
single would you do that be unicorned
into a relationship would you [__]
someone's wife while they watch I think
so yeah really yeah I think so like in
Florida on a gig I would do that but
then it's like yeah as long as I don't
have to touch the guy I had a I used to
always get on the road when I was single
I would get so many
um random couples like regular looking
couples that would send me like they'd
hit you up through Facebook
not hot
like once you see them in the pictures
they send you oh that person's hot I
didn't realize they were hot right but
like teachers and [__] like just regular
jobs I think so many people in the
middle States when we travel like they
get married so young that they become
freaks yes exactly and um it was always
just so crazy I never would do it I feel
like some Comics out but I'm just like
it I don't I don't know I don't want
them to have I would want them to sign
an NDA or something I want them to have
that story about okay that's what I
wanted to ask you have you ever had a
girl sign an NDA have you ever had
anyone sign an NDA before
um doing anything sexual to them no
because I recently drafted an NDA really
for somebody and I was like wait is this
a bad move
um only because
I I don't know like just I'm a little
bit insecure about like the internet
yeah the internet yeah that's so like
celebrity Vibes of you so
congratulations well hang on can I read
my NDA yeah oh my God is this allowed
I'm the happiest I've ever this is the
juiciest thing it was a really quick
it's like three sentences long way
they'll have to find it so
[Laughter]
uh okay so disappointing now guys that
hang out with you are like wait I don't
yeah you don't care it was kind of half
jokey but basically it says I blank name
willfully agree to never speak of change
narrative or mention any relation sexual
or not with kalila I hereby give full
confidence to kalila the retelling of
our sexual Rendezvous for her to share
all forms of her creative storytelling
in all its forms here and after are
consensual this is not an NDA this is
you getting like a contract sign so you
can use the story oh really yeah yeah
but they can't right that's pretty good
is that I think a guy would be fine with
that he wasn't oh what no what'd my wife
say
he wasn't he said I reserve the right to
tell my friends if I'm excited about a
girl and he could tell a friend I can't
stand it I had okay so I had this like
hot New Zealand guy in my audience I've
talked about this a little bit he was so
hot that I was like I'm like I've never
been like I'm in a [__] audience
member but it was like I mean he was
just so hot that I was like I might have
to so I was kind of like joking flirting
with him from the stage and then
afterwards he was like okay what's up
let's go you know and I was like no I
don't know I don't think so because I
just didn't try I don't know I don't
want him like writing about me online
being a girl like well I just don't want
him like yeah it's like and then
everyone's coming to the shows like I
travel alone a lot of times it's like I
don't want them thinking they can [__]
me or whatever so then and then I was
like yeah I don't know man I I don't
know if I'm I'm down and then I did an
Instagram live and all of these like
dudes were on there like are you gonna
bang my friend I was like
buddy then he begged me he was like
police and I was like all right oh you
did it yeah oh nice I love that that's
so fun what's a hot guy to you he was
just I mean literally so like ripped
tall dark he was from he was um
I can't believe you said ripped yeah so
[__] He's from New Zealand yeah Maori
yeah oh
this is so [__] hot it was like a
professional athlete of course Annie you
had to it was I could not I'd resisted
for a while but then it was hot because
he was begging me so I was like oh wait
anyone else
I'm good no but it's like but it's so
different like guys it's like you guys
are you know when you're single or
whatever you can [__] every girl it's
tough because a lot of female Comics
like oh it's so unfair women get hit on
blah blah blah but then when women do
get hit on they're like I don't know
this is weird you guys are creeps and
I'm like which one is it ladies if you
want to get hit on do you know I don't
think it's unfair that you that I think
it's just it's not it's not like unfair
it's just like it's weird for me to [__]
the audience yeah we're different and
it's totally normal for guys right it's
not like I don't think it's unfair it's
just like different I agree because it's
like I mean imagine like you can go to
Annie Letterman shows and she'll suck
your dick like imagine what my shows
become if like Reddit was like right I
banged her I banged her I banged her be
insane yeah agreed you want to like
break that seal uh-oh sell out a world
tour oh thank you my jaw would hurt so
bad oh good what's going on here
there's a
little
pre-pussied
one's been in the [__] you have to
pick smells like Esther I know Esther's
[__] baby powder
paper ice cream
wait you don't like ripped no me neither
no we don't like like chubby chubby you
know I like chubby too but it's like
when you get a guy that's just like
smoking [__] hot
okay here's here's the deal if he's if
he's naturally just genetically
predisposed no not someone that just
like been pumping up but not a guy who's
just a Gym Bro out no way no I feel like
my middle school like my middle school
high school flame my like on and off
again was so like genetically ripped and
hot that it's like I I am like my mom my
mom doesn't really need to work out and
she's just ripped my uncle's in the same
way she's genetically gifted right but
if it's a dude with you know spends
eight hours at the gym really counts as
macros I'm out boiled chicken in a
tupperware oh yeah that guy's annoying
yeah yeah what is weird it's like what
are you doing and like are you competing
is this your thing well if you're in
competition sure that's one thing but if
you just do this yeah but I'm like not I
don't want to go to like my boyfriend's
like muscle competition
he's like at a speedo and [__] it's like
it really is pretty good it's super gay
and there's so much like fake it's like
spray tan like not like getting a spray
tan like like they're rubbing Tanner oh
no the Tanners that they use it's like
it's black body yeah they use like 10
times darker than it should be
I think like any like sign that men
acknowledge their own looks is like a
weird turn off okay like how like like
how like just like men that like care
about what they look like I don't I do
like guys with style though I do like I
used to always date skaters because I
feel like they like just have an
automatic style a lot of them and um but
I like this younger generation like the
boys with the nail polish or stuff I
think is actually pretty hot really I do
some necklaces on them but it depends
but they have to have like really good
bodies oh wow and they have to read
masculine in other ways got it there's a
guy on The Bachelorette who knits and
it's like I'm like he's got to be doing
it for [__] yeah he's so hot it's like
come on will you look this guy up he's
so hot why can't he just have a hobby
because and then things are unfolding
where he's like a cheater it's like yeah
you're a cheater
you pull them up he's so loud because I
feel like knitting on a really hot guy
is like a high level on a bachelor there
is some type of manipulation happening
there interesting ladies you're
interesting because I know a kid in the
90s who would just carry a camera like
on his neck and girls love the camera
and I'm like who gives it about the
camera like what about his face or his
body but like the camera's hot no you're
right I recently went on a date with a
guy throw the camera around his neck and
it's up here it was instantly hotter
because of it it's weird you gotta seem
like standing up he's like why are you
guys really a camera makes a guy hotter
I see that's why women are tough because
you're all different you guys out okay
Xavier and it's charity a blanket like
the sweetie he is he looks like nerdy
there though no he's not he's this is
the guy he's you have to see he's he's
hotter he's
but he sucks dick no he doesn't
so he turns out he's a cheater he's not
yes he is okay he's on The Bachelor he's
a bachelorette okay okay this is a good
season this which is hilarious
is this the Black season yeah but
there's still a white there's a white
guy at the end okay um and then the next
season is their first golden batch for
that one he's like that's just like
finally hilarious my Pace do they keep
the same age female contestants yeah I
know that's so scary no but the women
are only gonna be like 40 or something
they're gonna be like we have value and
they're 42 or something I literally want
my mom to be on that show so bad you're
dead He's 80. like We it's well this
guy's 70. is he 70 yeah he's got a
hearing aid he has a hearing aid and all
the jokes are he doesn't know what
social media is it's so funny no you
know what else I want them to do after
this spin-off is like like kind of like
our age because the bachelor was what
like they did 30. yeah they did um
Claire this one chick Claire Crawley oh
that was a disaster but left with a guy
yeah that she was there she's like too
old she was just like let's just leave
and then they had to bring in like
another person to finish the season
right bam Check Out Time to Pretend I
like all these guys yeah what about
Pacino just had a kid with a young lady
and so did Mick Jagger it's so weird how
old is Pacino gotta be 87. the kid's
gonna be [__] so rich like yeah at
least they'll be provided for him that
way kalila had a really old dad that
died when she was a teenager my dad died
when I was a teenager but he was 80 when
he died so he was born in 1924. wow he
had me in his well into his 60s wow but
these guys are older than that and
that's why she can't give good blow jobs
it's true her dad could never get hard
well I just recently learned um from
Corinne and Christina that guys can have
you when you're at home jerking yourself
off you don't have to be fully hard to
come you can be yes I don't know about
that apparently some dudes can be like
just half chub and still come eyes like
ever just tune into girls pockets and go
like they've got this completely wrong
we don't listen
yeah I guess you're right you're not
like I'm gonna go listen right we should
because it's good insights for guys guys
are so clueless on what you ladies are
into no we literally have half male
listeners okay there you go they should
listen and we give they learn nothing
absolutely nothing but that was a guy
who couldn't get hard he's like trust me
guys can come yeah yeah yeah it was but
no you got to be rock hard to shoot a
load really because I think that their
producer Dan was his name down
he was the guy in the room was like no
no you're right like you can get a half
chub and just come that way who's
producer
oh really yeah he was he corroborated
the story he was like you're right I
can't think of anything scarier in life
than like a soft dick coming
like that is that is so nightmare why do
you get the reward when you haven't even
like I hate everything about it you need
to stand up like the toilet seat
right when you walk in it goes up like a
barn with an Amish
yeah
uh oh soft yeah soft dick is tough even
as a married guy I hide the soft dick
really yeah yes it's a bummer nobody
wants to see that the turtle shell yeah
yeah it's like an acorn and a bush
[Laughter]
right full bush baby like that plant
over there but yeah if you don't mind
the hairs going up the shaft I lose I
might trim a little because you know you
want all the shaft you can get
why not that's got a hair and a gummy
bear in there who knows it's a mess well
bush is so funny
um it's been to the movies yeah it's
running mate is gore
that's an old reference George Bush
a good time a good time for politics a
fun time fun time yeah
um you voting for Trump I've never voted
actually
uh but I like this uh there's a couple
interesting candidates out there that
rfk's ripped yeah zadie he's a dilf yeah
but he's kind of sexy huh nobody no he's
cute he's a Kennedy there he is so hot
is he look at his little brother Bobby
Kennedy really yes no so clueless now
Annie do you think that Bobby was the
hottest I do for sure yes not John no
what about JFK Jr
he is really hot smoking oh yeah I like
how he yelled at his girlfriend too I
was like ooh they were fighting I know
the drama I love all the funny I was
like oh my God passion but the hottest
kid do you think he was banging her out
on the plane when they Annie it was a
small plane no he was flying it no dick
looked huge on the plane
yeah that guy's driving
he okay he is probably the hottest
Kennedy but personality wise I'm gonna
just predict the I love a typing cover
of murder
like I don't understand he like didn't
really accomplish anything in his life
and that's just like oh JFK Jr
but he he lost did you do you know this
like George magazine he launched this
like political sexy magazine and it kind
of is embarrassing to me that he did
that oh well because he never got to
come to full fruition let's just say he
came with a softie with a semi what are
you his life was like a child that
nutted I
um he had the hair swooped that was like
he would have just the celebrity
relationships he would have been in
because he had dated like just Sarah
Jessica Parker and stuff like he would
have gone yeah he would have gone so
much hotter and his last wife was really
pretty she looked like Uma Thurman yeah
yeah I feel like they were gonna stay
together and yeah are you an Uma Thurman
yeah I like a little bit of Uh
something's a little bit something wonky
you know a big dick I mean
I like a face it's not like Heidi Klum
doesn't really she's obviously hot but
she's a little wonky I like a stare at
Jessica Parker I like that big old Jazz
I love a big nose oh especially a big
nose on a woman is so sexy to me
Jennifer Gray she got a nose job it was
so weird weird that was her whole thing
I agree with you I think um perfect
symmetry is boring agreed like Chris
Hemsworth great but also I feel like
just like boring to look at over time
for me like I find like just the same
thing where something's got to be off a
weird mole somewhere it's like Adrian
Brody like that oh my God the big nose
or Ryan Gosling hot take the face is
crazy looking yeah I think you're right
I'm sure in person he's like stunning
his face is very he's not yeah he's
various he's like a hot slot the same
really hey you good oh yeah I don't know
if the eyes are closed yeah the ones
like winky kind of lazy yeah and there's
been work done to make it more because
it's been crazier in the past that's
probably why he's cool the hair is off
yeah
but it is and the nose is a little yeah
interesting it's just blonde men I'm
sure I'd be fully like like slipping on
my own pea juice if I saw him
for you I want you to get scared
so who's your number one
every gal's got a number one I used to
say uh leave Schreiber but what Ben
Whitney told me I just Ray Donovan like
I just wanted to just [__] him through
the screen
I had no idea and then
um like the Jews I do I know I really
haven't dated you seriously but I do
yeah I like him too my the ladies
mine is recently but who's yours uh
Google Al-Qaeda ah what a funny sentence
it should already be on a tab Bin Laden
is not bad looking by the way Bin Laden
but Bin Laden is yeah he likes Filipinos
I'm in wait Kyla what about you I feel
like at one point yours was like a sumo
wrestler yeah is that still what do you
really think he's hot he's got a decent
face no Bin Laden is hot no it's more
like I don't know I need to see under
the beard I can't decide if someone's
hot unless I've seen no more like I'm
not getting tricked like that more the
young guys like the Isis guys really I
agree with you Esther I can't believe I
actually agree with you on this but I
think you're right the dark features the
hairy the big beard is very attractive
for sure but what is yours
um recently I've had had I've gone from
any Edgar Ramirez I don't know who that
is is that my Gardener
who's that he's a Venezuelan actor oh
yeah he's like um but recent but my
whole life it's been you guys know this
is Bill Murray what yeah a hero you
could get him Bill Murray or Idris Alba
either is fine wait okay but did you
watch hijack I haven't on Apple it's
starring Idris Elba you guys it's the
best it's so good and he's amazing in it
that guy what about
um that looks like what I'm gonna look
like when I'm older
I think I look more like him honestly
um what about did you guys see this I
just watched the show last night it was
getting me so girl boned up but um what
was the uh normal people it's like oh my
I was losing Todd's like this guy's ugly
like Todd you do not know what I'm
following every guy thinks is ugly on
I'm like I'm already following him on
Instagram have you so I read this I have
like books I should have read the book I
am losing my mind over the show Todd
made me turn it off to watch Big Brother
I'm like I am so horny like why are you
doing this to me blue balled me this
show over the pandemic I am like me and
such I love spell I can't because I read
the books I love Sally Rooney but but
this guy like I can understand thinking
is that I want to [__] destroy them I
want to circumcise his penis with my own
my own Annie cigars I want to [__]
because I want to just make it happen
yeah Paul I want to [__] that foreskin
off him what is it about him it must be
his character it's like he's rude he's
rude he's brooding he's a [__]
[__] but he's kind of sweet
that's just good but they go in on that
show they go full Bush they show
everything yeah and Todd's like Todd's
like why would you have a full Bush on
him because it's Grote like you can't
show like a shaved beave on TV but you
can show a bush like and that might even
be a merkin right they have to do that
do you know that one of the reasons why
people think that normal vaginas are
like the really closed ones that those
are the more common ones are because
and porno mags they used to say you had
they had a Photoshop out any like actual
lip showing because it was too it was
like a great pornographic wait do you
have like a TV character movie character
or like a celebrity that's your like
number one I'm all over the road I do
like uh SJP uh Salma Hayek I know is a
little hacky but she's a sexy lady
um come on look at that I like you're
still age-appropriate it's good I like
older I mean she's got to grow with them
too yeah unbelievable she's got to be
50. what about Sofia Vergara yeah too
cartoony yeah she's like a you know
[Laughter]
also she's got she feels like she smells
like a tortilla you know like she seems
like a real Mexican but she's obviously
hot but yeah but it's not you're like
yeah it's like hanging out with her
would be like all right can you tone it
down with the uh that's one that's one
of mine actually oh
I get that
that's not a bad choice Pete oh Amanda
Pete very pretty oh yeah I like a big
mouth now have you seen she's gone
private government no pull it up oh no
no I'm thinking of someone else I'm
thinking of someone else so you're into
your mouth I like about like big wacky
features yeah huh look at that that's a
[__] ear to hear now when you're at
dinner with your parents or you're like
hey past the like is that how you talk
to them I don't speak
scared of them still scared him he's
like what do you do for a living comedy
that's what could traumatize you into it
yeah do you try to be funny around them
no no no well they're not big laughers
so oh my God
it was brutal and I have friends come
over and they're like man your parents
see it's tough to get a reaction I'm
like yes welcome to my world my parents
are the opposite well my mom will give
me just deadpan she'll be like she
thinks my mom like her favorite things
like jackass really she loves like Eric
Andre's movie she was like crap when he
got pulled naked yeah she was howling
that's a cool mom howling but if if I'm
doing my dad thinks everything I say is
funny and my dad and I will have like
we'll just we'll have these like moments
that are like we're crying we're
laughing so hard and we'll come home and
tell my mom to try to include her yeah
and she she'll go I don't get it and
we're like you [__] [__]
[__] live [__] like open up like
what are you she's adopted I'm like
We're Not Gonna Leave You
so keep this attitude up I couldn't get
my mama to watch Jackass if I had a gun
to her head really well it's too low
brow she's very cultured and she reads
and drinks a glass of wine and listens
to classical but that's kind you went to
film school right yeah
I did but I still like jackass I like
[__] up [__] I like farts yeah you
know and it farts her forever I I listen
I follow this guy on Instagram he
doesn't have a big following but it's
just farts I think that's his Instagram
handle just farts just farts and it's in
the dark all it's just a video in the
dark there's no asses or anything it's
just sounds and he's like Anonymous I
don't like that show your face if you're
gonna be fart guy I want it to ruin your
career right I want you to have to be
fart guy I don't have other options
right I definitely don't agree with you
guys on the fart stuff
being cute or fun I don't think it I
don't I don't think it is I would blast
you out about if I was your man yeah
part you out of this world
[Laughter]
fall right and you don't want that
toilet seat down I would pulling you
into the toilet but I agree with you um
in the 10 years I was with Bobby I never
farted in front of him oh my god well I
didn't say that so you do fart in front
of Dave I'm not saying that either but I
just don't think fart humor is like like
if someone walked in the room and was
like let one out and thought it was
funny it'd be like pull my finger is
like hacky it's not sure yeah but like
and I there's some people but the
I've had the luck of my last few
boyfriends Todd included they've
accidentally left shits in the toilet
like kind of early on so I'm like but
I'm like thank God because it's like all
right you broke the seal right oh no you
didn't flush it you didn't hold the
thing down that was their worst mistake
I like rigged the toilet what are some
early mistakes a girl can make
that's a good question I think uh
flipping out like having a meltdown too
early is a huge turn off because you're
like all right I gotta get out of this
it's gonna be my life yeah yeah just
over small things yeah what if it's
warranted that's fine that's because
Warren's fine but just like snapping
like I'm just having a bad day that
whole thing you're like all right I'm
out this gal's uh ticking Time Bomb
that's a tough one
um gross stuff doesn't bother me like
you know if a girl has like toilet paper
on her shoe or has like a little
you know weird panty thing you know it's
a weird thing in there you know our
snail Trail yeah that's fine because
that's natural
it's more like crying over nothing
you know like
she had a bad day at work and she's like
I just said no one respects me and
you're like ah this is brutal poor
self-regulation yeah yeah so that that's
a tough one so I would say go fart
diarrhea it up on the walls but uh the
the freaking out or snapping snapping on
a friend stuff like that that's tough
you know you're right that's the first
thing I look for when I'm dating a guy
is whether or not they could potentially
have a temper or snap potential yeah
because that's really scary to me I hate
it my dad was that way and it [__] me
up saying my mom was super Snappy and so
I would it's like I I had a very
eggshell type of childhood so when I
look at a dude I'm like okay like I like
to see him under a certain amount of
stress to see how he copes yeah you
should make little obstacle courses
or like you as well there's cheese and
Esther not even in like a gamey kind of
way but I will kind of create obstacles
where I'm like okay if I don't respond
to him in a certain whatever you know
like let's say I'm having a busy day I
want to know how he responds to that
sure because if it's in any type of way
like
even weird and if we're still in the
first three months like that's a red
flag for me I just always need because I
my 80d is so crazy so it's like I just
think I was like patient so I can always
tell when we're ordering food like if
I'm taking too long like because I had a
boyfriend who would like yell at me if I
was taking too long and that's like I I
can't have someone like touching me or
whatever it's like yeah I'm like busy I
got things going on up here right but so
I can always kind of like tell in those
situations it's like a patience is like
what I need yeah because it's like I'm
it's for me to retrain my ADD would be
like almost impossible oh yeah it's too
far gone I've never I've like never
observed a red flag I feel like I could
just date anyone I'm so pathetic we also
think that we've also seen the wrong
store and go wow anyone
complaining is tough too like a guy or
girl like if I had a guy friend who was
like I'm just tired I'm cold
I like somebody who can rally you know
after like half like she got out of her
car today she was like and I was like
what's right I thought it was like
obviously like something had happened in
her life she wants it's just so hard I'm
like oh my God this door is like right
there
you can make it I don't notice weather
that's what's so funny like you're so
temperature I can't believe you don't
notice I can't go unless something
insane is going on it's like freezing
yeah it's so hot like I go to the car I
come back and we're gonna try to be like
are we like what what should I wear a
jacket or I'm like I have no [__]
clue wow sometimes like complaining is
not even complaining it's sort of like a
bid for connection it's just it's like
when you tell me like I'm cold and it's
I'm like let me get you a blanket it's I
always see it as like I don't think
she's really that cold she just wants to
be babied or wants to be mothered in
this well you know that in her now so
yeah you know how to yeah I feel like
though I've had it with my with with my
friends like if you when you first
become friends it's like you Bond on
like hating the same people yeah you
know how the friendship's gonna end
right they're gonna start hating you or
talking [__] on you or whatever or if
like you like I have friends where it's
like we've I've complained to them about
things so much that like when they call
I know it's going to be complaining and
I have to be like yes hey let's not do
complain today let's not do that and
it's it's almost impossible because I've
trained them to do that right like if
I'm annoyed with something they're doing
I did I established that yeah it's good
you can realize it yeah but I'm trying
it's like it's hard and then you want to
be rude to people because you want them
to have their feelings but it's like
yeah God damn I'm like they're I'm like
10 affirmations in you know I'm like
I'll just be able to deal with it
my friend that's like come on look at
the positive when they're like right I'm
just like you got to call someone else
it can't be me today I can't do it yeah
I agreed good one yeah that's high
pressure I I have friends who will not
take any less than an hour of your time
like so if they call I have to know if I
pick up this phone call committing to an
hour because they just are kind of
long-winded a little bit a lot to ask
yeah so most of the time I'll be like
hey I'll I'll call you this weekend when
I have time actual time for you yeah I
know and I'm so worried about bothering
people that I I could never do that
somebody
I would want to call somebody for an
hour yeah that's Insanity well you're so
busy liking every single person's things
they post you're so good at that well I
just feel bad like oh they're gonna be
sad this is the first time I've ever
find in my text I forgive you but oh and
I understand but this is the first time
ever since I've known you I'll respond
after this just okay keep the yeah and
rolling so you're so good you wish
everyone their happy birthday yeah it's
so sweet really I don't want to leave it
sweet or psychotic I don't know a little
of both but it's every it's like it's
wild Norman's in there always since the
beginning since I met you that's so like
polite and but like that's what I got it
my inner child needs that kind of
consistency is what my inner child
craves someone who you know is not gonna
miss
you've like called me like hours I've
been sorry I was skiing like you're good
oh yeah
yeah you're fearful I think fearful I
don't leave anyone to hang because I
know the pain of being left hanging so I
love living here buddy you grew up in
like a sort of egg Shelley oh yeah big
eggshell
well speaking of eggshells this egg has
hatched this has been a great thank you
so much on the special tonight on
Netflix it's so funny and like just
great and original and weird definitely
watch it Tuesdays with stories are we
drunk is that what it is we might be
drunk outside are you garbage okay you
might be drunk everywhere
um you know you love them check out
definitely just check out a special and
thank you Mark we hope to see you again
soon thank you this was Illuminating and
a great time and I'm still bummed about
the no BJ
comedy hi guys thank you thank you that
was fun
thank you
[Music]